i'm pretty interested to see where
dows go when you listen to crypto people
talk about crypto they're so optimistic
they're so idealist and like you go use
some of these things and you're like
this sucks i mean so you were in on this
dude buying the constitution yeah i
think marcus bought me some he
contributed for me and then sent me the
the token that you get so for people
to contribute to this if you don't know
what we're talking about
uh a dao is a decentral decentralized
autonomous organization right it okay
it's kind of
like a programmable llc yeah with
programmable governance and stuff in it
so it's like a company that you can
create an organization that you can
create that you guys can fund and then
you can program the rules
of how you use those funds how the
company runs
which has pretty crazy implement
implemented are you implications sorry
stop stop
is your brain
dude i have a speech impediment okay all
right just i do too but i'm not okay
yeah you're just you know that was like
a lot like i'm running a row
you said implementations well because
implementations is kind of similar and
so my brain just like got the two of
those mixed up real fast it has very
interesting implementations and
implications and implementations yeah it
does so that's kind of like a new word
yeah so it wasn't really a fumble i'm
way ahead i'm playing chess yeah
um implementations yeah and it's like
one of those things where it's like no
one knows how they're gonna use these
but
in a in an experiment
people created one and then they
basically said hey
they found out that they were gonna
auction off one of the copies of the
original us constitution at sotheby's
and
they were like let's raise money and buy
it
as a dow
and so they raised 40 million dollars in
three days as a canadian i don't know if
you should be allowed
to own part of a car i know it's true
right yeah yeah oh you're a citizen now
well here's the thing is that you don't
actually own a part of the car that's
right you own a part of the company that
owns the constitution and then you get
to decide what they do with it basically
yeah so it doesn't really mean anything
and
as a contributor your tokens only
are worth what someone else will pay for
them obviously but anyone else would
want in
because they'd want to decide what to do
with the constitution which really isn't
that cool of a thing you know what i'm
saying yeah so it was kind of a weird
experiment and they got
owned by the ceo of citadel
probably like next in line to the devil
yeah so basically they like
they were at sotheby's and
they the auction ended and i think
coindesk or something tweeted that
they won or we won sorry i'm part of it
so we won
and then turns out it was incorrect and
they found out that they got outbid in
the last second
and
and it came out like a couple hours
later that i was [ __ ] this guy
in griffin because obviously yeah the
amount is
like on display yeah they like didn't
show no i it was on display because you
can look up the dow's address and you
can see exactly how much ethe is in
there that's like one of the big
criticisms of daos is like there's no
corporate secrecy which
you know
tends to lead to bad things but you do
need some degree of like trade secret
yeah yeah
so that sucks he just had a crypto nerd
on his team and they're like
he's like
one cent over yeah apparently that's
what the final bet was was one cent over
with the dow raised it was just such a
big [ __ ] you so if you guys don't know
who ken griffin is he's the ceo of
citadel who pays for order flow from
robin hood and they're the entire reason
why the gme thing happened and it was
basically
griffin was like the face of the hedge
funds and like the you know
classic
um
old money yeah yeah and like he was
basically the one that was saying [ __ ]
you to the retail trader because he
essentially got trading stopped that's
what people were saying he's he's next
in line to the devil man he's a bad
person
and so in this case a bunch of crypto
people got together because they were
like let's do something really cool and
let's test out the limits of this
technology and ken griffin was like nah
yeah that's pretty indicative of
real life what a message to send yeah
you know yep guess what crypto dick bags
you'll never beat us billionaires always
win yeah
uh yeah y'all are excited about dows uh
it's more like ba billionaires always
win pal yeah
so
yeah shove that up your ass the virgin
the virgin dao does not own a copy of
the constitution announces max bid prior
to the auction
burns millions on ethereum network gas
fees doesn't win auction that's another
funny thing is that like the gas fees
were so big in the heat of everyone
contributing that it cost a [ __ ] ton to
even contribute yeah and then at the
when they didn't win they were like okay
you can you can request for your funds
back through whatever the network they
did the dial through but the gas fees
were like
just as much as people contributed so
you couldn't even get your money back
rip the easiest front running i ever did
paid exactly one cent more than dow max
bid
this will pair well with my
100 million dollar basket yeah and my
238 million dollar penthouse only gas
fees paid on day of auction we're for a
private jet yeah what's it like being a
virgin dow owner i mean
sucks
it's not fun dude i'm keen on this
motorsport dao i'm gonna do it man yeah
you should
power sports expensive man it's like um
yeah noel wants to join f1 there's like
hilarious stories of dudes getting into
f1 that just should not have been there
because like they literally can't keep
up there's like a rule like there's like
a equation of like your timing and if
you don't fall within the time like you
just you can't race like you get your
license revoked and they say goodbye
that would be me like on the practice
day yeah it'd be like hey uh
he's gonna die out here yeah so he's got
to go and you're like okay guys you can
request your money back
and nobody can because the gas yeah
so i just yeah maybe
let's vote on what else i should not be
able to race in
maybe formula two the money in formula
one is so wild so this a new chinese
driver he took a seat at
uh alfa romeo uh guan yi zhou he
apparently it was something like i heard
a rumor that he just showed up with like
[ __ ] 10 mil
or or more which is like sign me 10 mil
and
they have this other driver they call
him italian jesus that dude got the boot
so swift they're like man
it's nice knowing you really yeah why
because he doesn't have because he
doesn't have 10 mil because the the
sport is so [ __ ] expensive
or i think you may have showed up with
more but i think yeah yeah no he showed
like 10 and gave it to f1
yeah so it's weird like who makes the
money my understanding of formula one is
it's almost like literally like media
creation where the drivers are the
talent
and they
they bring investment so it's either
through a sponsor or um
whatever could be their own money like
if they're [ __ ] rich as [ __ ]
and
they pay themselves out of salary but
like that's why it's the same grind as
like jake paul anyone else like they're
just selling merch to try to actually
make some money from it um and then they
hope they win but if if you don't win
you're just you're just literally
burning cash
it's nuts wow the winnings are crazy
though so you know if we start my f1
down if we
just just beat like ferrari or mercedes
yeah it's just no big deal honestly
power of the internet we can do it but
you won't see any of that money
but you will get your face on the car
you will get your face on the car yeah
yeah you'll own your face on the car
and that's it